how's it going everyone my name is ping
pang and welcome to Friday's with pain I
really don't have much time today I had
a really busy day and it's Friday's
nearly finished so I have to hurry up
before Friday's over thank you so much
for leaving all the questions to me I
got 213 questions to answer for the QA
but I could of course I can't answer all
of them so I pick up picked out a few of
them my girlfriend helped me so I
haven't like read them and be like oh I
got I don't even know what I'm talking
about but anyway I have the decided that
I'm gonna host a competition for you
guys for my fans and the idea is that I
get so many people riding me like hey
check out my channel and very Berber I
usually don't have time for that it's
just too many things at once it's like
I'm doing this and if I go check out my
channel like I do it sometimes but I
wanna I want
Friday Friday's would be really bad to
be for you guys basically and me giving
something back to you
so this competition will basically be
that you'll you'll write in the comments
if you want me to enter the competition
all you have to do is write pew and then
pwe of course and then write whatever
like hey come hump my grandma or
something I don't know and I'll check
out your channel and it'll be like a
competition so the channel that I
thought I liked most or I think the most
deserve more viewers
I will promote in the next week's
Friday's we'd be like I need a sub there
but that's pretty much the idea I think
I think it could be fun of course you
have to be like it's only for my fans so
if I see that you're not a subscriber
then that's the only rule I think and
yeah you should box me because I will
box you for put me on your sub box
because I'll put the winner in my sub
box for the next week and then if it
goes well I'll might do another week but
and of course like it's not just one
winner if if I find more channels that I
think is really good then of course I'll
promote them as well it's not about that
I don't know it's for you guys I'm doing
I say yeah I thought that could be
pretty cool remember just to write pew
and whatever it it's it really doesn't
matter if you have millions of
subscribers or two subscribers I really
that's not what I'm looking for I'm
looking for good content and yeah sorry
this would be a really long episode
because I have to answered the questions
and now like I said I had 213 but I
picked two pages of comments so I feel
like a news anchor or something like I'm
a paper have my headphones like this
just in something like I could be a news
anchor good night well okay let's not
get sidetracked there the first question
is from t-rex ate my girlfriend and he
is asking have you thought about doing
maybe as some subscriber Sunday Saturday
sort of thing or try hosting blah blah
okay yes I have thought about doing that
I'm not definitely gonna do that and
that'll be something like I'll do and I
upload that for frying sweeping here
back okay uh cell yeah we Dowe cell cell
away DD Phi solo we defy there we go uh
if you could create a master hahaha
spell wrong anyway Austrian Alicia what
would it be like um sort of like the bro
but give him
like the bro and penis monster combined
- wow that would be pretty epic I think
just saying it's a penis to be bro
anyway innit
not for that Rasmus HD what is a
scariest moment you ever experienced in
real life not while playing a game and
can't wait to get a shirt with a shared
moment charge I don't really remember I
remember when I was a kid I remember it
really well but it seems like more like
a dream but I remember seeing a skeleton
and he's sat down on the that's all I
can think of like I don't really know I
haven't been liking in dear near-death
experience or anything like that I'm up
but crazy anyway yet cyborg hey Peter I
to questions how did you come up with
your name and what do you do to make
your videos like software and recording
programs I'm going to answer the last
question first because that's it's
pretty pretty common question I record
with fraps I wonder if I if I got a
penny for every time I said that I would
be a rich no but seriously everyone
asked me that and it's perhaps if you
want to record with highest quality
possible-- you want to use fraps that's
just how it is
and then the second question is but the
files are so big what do we do and it's
you have to render them and edit them
and I use Premiere Pro it's if you want
to use that it I think there's a 30 day
of 30 day three three three I can't talk
today I'm sorry I'm really tired trial
if you want to try it out I recommend
Premiere you can use Sony Vegas to just
download illegally who cares I mean
and yeah keep on making funny videos
yeah okay I'll try that
and I'll buy four four four four four
are you disappointed about disappointed
because the baby fountain doesn't want
to make out with you he's talking about
the baby fountain in abduction or
amnesia and yeah it makes like doc hurt
and it's like what who it's like saying
I want to make out with you like if I
ever do that face Wow
and you see it you can know that I want
to make out with you
and okay mr. t na Wrestling 2009 I give
a tour around your house and show us
your setup it's gonna take a while
this is just temporary room I'm living
with my parents right now and I'm moving
in a couple weeks but I can show you my
room and cuz my webcam really can't do
much they've seen Madison opinion before
and this is this is what you I look like
this is um you guys I suppose
hey you look handsome and infinity yeah
okay um yes and there we have my bad
this is really poorly very do this why
TV I never watch TV seriously um and
then I guess I have to show my setup a
screen is a 24 inch keyboard is a gaming
Microsoft Sidewinder is really great
keyboard you can like punch it and
select if you get mad same with
Microsoft Mouse gaming mouse pad I
definitely recommend a gaming mouse pad
again it really helps you improve your
games getting skills okay I don't know
if you can see down here it's pretty
dark ah I can't see anything okay here
we have Beth done oh he's a beautiful oh
but not Beth damn she's a friend
I don't know if I should open her and
tell all the stuff I don't think I have
time for that today I'm sorry um
actually I'm think I'm gonna do it
because I get so many [ __ ] questions
about it all right perfect
I'm so well plan you guys this is
fridays with pewdiepie it's so
spontaneous anything could happen I
haven't opened Beth done in forever so
this should be good let's see if
everything I hit my head why
why I just have to make sure you can see
it's pretty [ __ ] dark but whatever
okay graphics card and vidya GTX 460 I
think wow this is some nerdy and
interesting isn't it
PSU 600 no one cares about that I have
AI 7 processor 930 solid-state drive and
I'm a really shitty hard drive 6
gigabytes RAM Western something ddr3 I
think no they're not was I I don't even
know and a really bad overpriced
motherboard Asus p5 something something
I don't remember but yes and the case is
a red fractional design or something
Swedish developer yes yes yeah you for
Sweden okay we're back okay yes where
did my questions go wow this is gonna be
the longest episode ever already okay
honey hurry up gravity - where are you
from I'm from Sweden and Gothenburg and
can you speak some Swedish maybe a crash
course in Swedish with beautify and I
think we all have time for that tonight
today - whatever but I could say
Chalobah here like it guy hit the pin
bad Nicky nice area Vegeta Oh hmm okay
English back in English ah xx the crunch
xx can you please please please convince
your girlfriend the Kahuna blog or at
least one of your gameplay I since my
girlfriend choose these questions for me
I would assume that he sort of wants me
to be in them but she says she's not
really perfectly English but I'm gonna
convince her sure I'll do that
can you grow out your beard at least
once like full who asked that question
sorry I didn't got the name of that one
I think it would be an amazing challenge
I don't know I like it I like it like
this I don't want it to be like I like
like okay that was kinda awkward nice
pill our question when we least if for
us
if I get 100,000 subscribers I'll do it
SCOE lad 1 are you going to buy that
Alan yes it should be going up tonight
actually a video with me and more far
but Matt it's a lot of it's a really
buggy game so and we had a lot of
trouble with recording and then
rendering is that I got a blue screen
while recording it so hey 3 hey 3 3 3 PT
PI what inspired you to start doing
common gaming commentaries on YouTube
the I don't really know I like I've been
wanting to make YouTube on I wouldn't
wanted to make youtube I was wanting to
make videos for YouTube for so freakin
long I haven't really no idea where I
got the idea from I just as soon as I
got the right equipment I started
recording but I don't think that's right
I think if you want to make it as a
youtuber I don't know or just you should
definitely have the right equipment
there's no doubt of that about that
there's there's just too many people
doing this for people with shitty
quality to make it but I don't fully
fully believe in that I think it takes a
lot of experience and practice at least
I think I speak a lot differently in
these videos than I did when I started
so why if you have a shitty camera just
go with the shitty camera and you'll get
the experience and practice of becoming
a good commentator so yeah
alpha Sol 7a two questions left by the
way how are you still with me are you
sleeping
I'm so interesting it's so crazy I know
I know I know alpha Sol 7 how long and
hard was it to reach your current
position it wasn't that long and it
wasn't that hard I've been wanting to me
like when I started started making
videos I wanted to become partner that
and that was like a goal for me
but I started off like a cob commentator
and that was that was more difficult and
when I started when I'm Nisha that's
really when I bloomed out no it went
pretty well with commentator 2 I would
probably have a decent amount of
followers if I did I polish like nobody
Christian and what was what's your
amnesia picture when they were first
let's play or did you make some before
but then upload it and if it's your
first do you have any tips for newbie
let's play like me to be also like oh
thank you um yeah it was my first let's
play so I don't really know the thing
that I think one of the first things I
said in my let's play and what really
made it successful was that I said I'm
not gonna pretend that I'm not scared
I'm I'm just gonna be me and like show
me and I think that's the most important
thing like just let loose show people
your personality don't try to be someone
else I wasn't trying to be like oh I'm
so badass look at me uh playing amnesia
I'm not scared of it remember but yeah
that's pretty that's just be yourself
have fun that's the most important thing
and um if you have fun in your videos
and I will refer reflect to your
to the one who's watching it and they
will be an enjoyable to watch and people
will subscribe if that's what you want
and that was all the questions yeah I
bet it I can be click ok Cheers
ok this is real I've been going off way
too long
thank you for watching this episode
don't forget to enter the competition I
think it's gonna be pretty cool I can't
wait to see what you guys have to offer
and that's it for this Friday sweeping
any pain
hey I'll do 360 for you guys only
business finest we paid about